you can kind of see in their body
language and something like you're
trying to turn old like what's going on
but it's similar what do you mean
because um
there aren't many men in the church
there aren't there aren't many men in
the church no i think it's like 70 women
yeah
yeah
because the men don't get behind this
they're like i came to church for a pure
wife why are these hoes in the church
and then now they're going to make me
wait
when the last guy got it for the last 10
guys got it for free yeah men don't get
with this [ __ ]
i think i think that is such a
backwards strategy by women right which
is why there's so many like single women
in the church like it's it's just
distracted
you're you're balling backwards like
really and truly are balling backwards
because it's like
if you think that going to church
is going to get you the man that you
want when the church is mostly women and
most of the men in church are already
taken we like
that's not the place
you're better off doing this you're
better off going to the club or i don't
know to the bar or i don't know
a lot of women do that a lot of women do
i think they they start off going to
church thinking oh yeah i'm gonna go to
church and maybe i might find a good man
but when you really actually delve into
the faith i'm not going to say religion
because it depends on what kind of
things they did find a good man but yeah
if you
yeah
i'm saying like when you when a person
goes to church and they delve into the
faith it becomes it moves away from
looking for a man you're not you're no
longer looking for a man you're looking
for your relationship with god once you
gain that relationship with god for
whatever you do
no no no you just actually you do you do
because you then i feel like most of the
things that you speak about they are
within women of faith no
no i think there's some situations
savage because i'm not going to lie it
depends on what type of church you go to
that's what i'm saying
no
at the moment no okay but
but
it literally depends on which ones you
go to because
some
are there are women that will go
to find their husband
and the husband might already be taken
so then it now becomes a family affair
inside the church it is common in
certain
i can't necessarily say what type of
church is but there are a few that it
really is
savage the issue with churches is that
one it tells girls that you need to find
a guy that's an equally yoked as you yes
and there aren't no i've been in a lot
of different churches they all say the
same thing you need to find a guy that's
equally yolked
what happens there aren't enough guys in
the church there's one guy usually for
every three girls so so they're you
can't find the guy that's equally yolked
right on top of that they they also want
you to donate it's like that ties or
whatever 10 of your income now how what
now most women are on track to be
homeless when they're 65. they're one
cancer diagnosis away from being on the
streets because they don't have the 2.5
million to retire they need to retire
now i know here you guys have saved nhs
yeah yeah but at some point that stuff's
going to run out they can't do it
forever
well it's been going for a very long
time yeah
there's going to be there's going to be
problem they're predicting that in a lot
of major cities there's going to be a
lot of issues because like a lot of the
social safety nets that are
unsustainable even in england
which is true and but
we're used to it we're accustomed to it
we will find a way
they'll and then they won't figure this
away with the government but going back
to what's happening that's what women do
they always assume somebody else is
going to take care of their poor
decisions but going back to the church
though pearl right like i said my old
anecdotal story that you would have
heard yeah um that whole equally yolk
thing like
women when when it comes to 70 the
church being female and
there are all the men in the basically
all the men in the church are taken the
women are going to have to go outside of
the church to find a man and then when
they find a man outside of the church
the pastor says oh
he's not equally old get rid of him so
the church is perpetually keeping women
single it depends on the church and this
is my point it's not going to church is
not to come and find a man going to
church is to strengthen your
relationship with god who is a man
people yes he's a man he's whatever you
want you are going to find amanda you
you will find a man but my point is if
you go to church without the intentions
of i'm going here specifically to look
for a man
you will end up finding the correct man
if you strengthen your relationship with
god if you understand your faith more
you will end up going out and you will
meet a man he may not be equally yoked
at the time but you're like you know you
were saying about like a woman that's
supportive a woman that's encouraging
xyz if you're looking for a man of faith
you will find a man that may want that
faith and he will eventually become just
as faithful as you are church is not
foreign then why are there then why are
there so many single childless women in
the church right they're they're they're
going to heal no but i'm saying
but i'm saying that you're the results
are not there if what you're saying was
true then there would be results to show
for it but there in every church i go to
even even in england it is three women
for every one man there is a surplus of
single childless women
and so like what you're saying isn't
correct because if it was correct there
will be results to show it yeah i don't
know i go to a church and every
every month there's at least two people
being
married okay so how many are in the
congregation they're in the congregation
what percentage of women would you say
is in your church
it's probably the same percentage you're
saying right
there like at that church some of them
some of them met at the church some of
them met outside the church and came to
the church some of them
yeah some of them met at the church or
some of them were introduced through the
church if that makes sense i'm saying
that's that's exception not the rule so
that that happens i'm starting to
realize yeah you've been on this podcast
i'm clearly um
no but it's not because you said even in
your church it's three women to every
one guys that means at least two are
single that means the majority of women
even in your church are single
yes but the point is the rate of
marriage
is quite high in the church people are
in serious relationships but that's not
that's not quite high if two out of the
three girls are saying i don't know the
the full percentage but what i see
is that when you're going to church at
some point all of those men are going to
be married yeah off and they're still
going to be 70 of women left in the
church other men coming to the church
but my whole point is church is not to
go and look for men
so if you take that out of the equation
you may find the correct man i i
understand so if you take a church at
the equation you may find the correct
man no i'm saying if you take
go into church to look for a man out of
the equation you will find the correct
man the church is about your faith
sounds like manifestation i i understand
i understand what you're saying
that
you shouldn't go to church to um to look
for a man
but with with what pearl is saying there
comes a point
in women's life they realize
i
i need a certain type of man because i'm
going to get to a point where my
eggs ain't egging no more and i'm
getting old and i know that a good man
is in church so let me go
find god in a church and yes you
shouldn't i don't think you should do
that because it's like you're going
there with the wrong intentions but that
is the mindset of some
women is that they do go there to find
somebody so that they don't end up alone
when you go there
as your
self who's now found god
what obligation does that man in church
who may be a quote quote good man have
towards you and your madness
this isn't like you're coming to him
with all of this baggage like oh i found
god now but really and truly you don't
understand how men think men aren't
thinking oh she's found god now men are
looking at your baggage saying
do i really want to get involved with
that like it doesn't matter church or
not it could be mosque i don't care
church mosque synagogue it doesn't
matter where you go
that's that's the i mean you know god
might heal but but the men don't forget
and that's the lie that's the lie that
that like oh my gosh i have a whole bit
on how church markets being a hoe i
swear to god i said that yeah sorry
because this is what they do they tell
girls you can do whatever in your 20s
you can get ran through and then all you
got to do is apologize mean it and then
there's a husband waiting for you at the
end
and then and then on top of that then
then they give those girls a platform to
go talk to younger girls and say hey i
was so broken
i was so broken and then and then i
found god later and now look at me and
i'm so happy i waited the second time
around and i got married so this is a
mating strategy that only benefits women
and doesn't benefit man because what
does the second guy get he gets a rant
through wife
who
maybe had one or two baby daddies that
now now he has to wait for like then
this is what happens is the church
leaves women single because they they
tell girls to do this
that's a terrible plan the church keeps
women perpetually single like i don't
think people understand like the church
is not a place for you to go and find a
man it will i said if it's not the
pastor keeping you single then it's the
actual actions of the people within the
church keeping you single because the
judgment
that happens a lot of the time in church
when a woman gets with a guy who's not
in church right and they start saying oh
is he in the church no he's not oh so
he's he's of the world or he hasn't or
or you have to bring him to the church
yeah what the like and what what leader
guy that's a leader that is alpha that
has the traits of a leader is going to
want to follow his woman to church
especially with the way churches are
today because even these mating
strategies they only benefit women
and they see the church for the women
you're not going to church for each
other you're going to church for god if
you invite god into your relationship it
will help to heal your relationship and
that's what like this whole thing of
like forgetting about a past yeah you
cannot forget about the past but it
depends on your behavior moving forward
and if your behavior let's let's exclude
sierra because we're not talking about
sierra here but if you if your behavior
moving forward is of a
faith in god manner
then god rules in your relationship and
you become
whole
do you know what that sounds like i want
to hear from okay do you know what it
sounds like as a man yeah god rules in
who's relationship
it's my relationship then if you've got
that mindset
you'll have a problem in your
relationship no but that's the but
that's the point you like women a lot of
women don't understand how men view god
and how women view god because the
reason why women gravitate towards god
is because he's a powerful man
whether it be conscious or subconscious
you put you gravitate towards god
because it's actually a powerful man and
women are attracted to powerful male
figures
and man is not sexually attracted to a
powerful male figure it's just not like
he doesn't see him like that
no but i'm right but what i'm trying to
say is the attraction for men for women
to be attracted to powerful men is
different than the attraction of a man
being attracted to a powerful man when
you are constantly
talking about
god
and your relationship with god have you
have you not heard women say i don't
need a man i've got jesus jesus is my
boyfriend jesus have you not heard women
say that